foreign
the fabric of our society is made up of
many threads
some of them are small street lights bin
collections potholes community centers
but some are huge like social care
few subjects are as unglamorous and
unscrutinized as local Council spending
have no Authority here Jackie
Jackie at all
but few things have as much direct
impact on people's quality of life and
pick at those threads year after year
and it adds up to the sense of the
social fabric the deal between citizens
and states is free
[Music]
we've come here to Oakham in Rutland
Rowland has one of the highest council
tax rates in the UK and it is a historic
Market Town it looks affluent as you're
driving through but a lot of people here
are really struggling to afford that
council tax
our story starts with the money we put
into the system nearly all of us have to
pay council tax but that's pretty much
the only consistent thing about it
and that variability points to some of
the issues with local government in
general all the way from input to
outcomes
Hannah Lucy and Zoe livinokum which
under Rutland Council has the highest
rate in the country
do you guys feel like you're getting
value for money from that that's true
no I
um
in lack of development in the town but
also an actual reduction in the
infrastructure and in the facilities
it's stripping back it's just making an
already unaffordable situation harder
yeah you know you've already
um trying not to turn your heating on as
much as possible to save those few extra
pennies and now there's a few extra
pennies are going to go into the
council's pocket people pay council tax
based on the type of property they live
in calculated all the way back in 1991
and the value it was then
it's tough for people like Lucy Zoe and
Hannah in Rutland they live in an area
with the highest council tax in the
whole of the country and over 2 400
pounds Nottingham Lewis Dorset and
Wilden not far behind all in the top
pairs of tax
by comparison three of the lowest paying
places are in London if you live in a
bandee property in Westminster you're
only paying 883 pounds for the privilege
when we look at proportion of income
people in Mole Valley Council area are
paying over eight percent of their
income on council tax but at the other
end of the scale in Southwest London
Wandsworth people are paying just 2.1
percent
council tax is the definition of a
postcode Lottery houses here in
Wandsworth can cost millions of pounds
but people are spending a lower
proportion of their income than people
in poorer areas and there's plenty more
inconsistency across the system
back in Oakham and it also looks well to
do the council argues they receive much
less funding from central government per
resident less than half than other areas
there is a fundamental message around
fairness to 504 pounds compared to 1019
pounds really simply isn't fair we'll
see just how much government funding has
fallen later on but if the money isn't
there councils have to make room for it
this is congleton a market town in East
Cheshire over recent years it's closed
down two recycling centers so this this
happened just last night yes uh about 10
o'clock last night a local resident put
on Facebook continent News and Views
about how disgusting and disgraceful
this flight to appears in the same
period fly tipping has soared as local
councilor Robert Douglas told us well
obviously as you can see here we've got
beautiful countryside and it's the real
I saw so as well as the financial cost
of pulling it all up we are seeing our
area being blighted tempers are fraying
too this driver stopped next to us to
complain
cleaned up and it might not seem like a
big deal but it is another tug on the
social fabric the relationship between
citizens and state if you keep tugging
all the time in enough places it feels
like it's starting to unravel
or batted roads this one on a school
route that hasn't been fixed in five
years
I mean more broadly does it feel you
know with carts with council tax going
up you're not getting much for it that
every year year after year things are
getting harder almost a Breaking Point
yeah it's totally like that the whole
highway system is broken Nationwide for
me
um the government again have to take it
more serious and start funding councils
um getting all the roads resurfaced the
all they do at the moment is put a bit
of cement air a bit of tarmac in uh it
rains heavily it gets Lefty so we need
something more sustainable
spending on roads has dropped from
nearly a billion pounds across all
councils 10 years ago to around 700
million pounds today street lights have
lost 100 million pounds in funding and
that's because councils are spending
more money on social care which they
have a legal duty to provide unlike
roads and Street lighting it's gone from
26 billion pounds 10 years ago to 30
billion pounds today even after
adjusting for inflation these are all my
Atari Jaguar games Cheshire East Council
spends 64 and a half percent of its
total budget on social Care on places
like this and on people like David Ryder
there you go Star Wars David is 57 years
old lives in full-time care in congleton
and is a massive fan of 80s New Wave
Music
[Music]
relaxing
good song my direction
he's worried about moving to New
accommodation in Macclesfield
some of that worry is because it will
take him further away from the highlight
of his month a disco for disabled people
run by volunteers
other community activities have been cut
by the council do you feel like there's
less services from the government to
help you it's about um the government to
did Pollock's weight in mental health
and also physical health I think even
previous to you being with us there was
a lot more things funded for you to do
wasn't there yeah and I think we've
definitely seen that cut back
in councils across the country demand
form and the cost of social care is
rising so carts have to be made
elsewhere
and those costs are pushing some
councils to the brink
Nottingham Castle was built nearly a
thousand years ago as an impregnable
Norman Fort even as a tourist attraction
though it's just as inaccessible
owned by the council it's been closed
since November when its trust went into
liquidation
this Castle is a symbol of a city and a
council facing financial distress but
it's not the only one our research shows
across the country councils are facing
real difficulties
that's meant cuts to vital services like
base 51 a youth center just around the
corner from the castle which has only
six months left in this property unless
it gets more funding before I started
coming here I was going out getting into
trouble
but since I started coming here or the
offer counseling and
obviously that's hoping got onto a
better path for one here I'll be getting
through everyday basically I'd probably
get arrested by now
Nottingham was forced to issue what's
known as a section 114 notice an
official Declaration of financial
distress it's not the only one Slough
thoric Croydon have done the same within
the last year and woking has warned it
might have to as well
the notices have come as councils
receive much less funding from central
government this shows the decline over
the last eight years a nearly 90 percent
drop
working in Surrey has racked up nearly 2
billion pounds in debt investing in
property developments like this and it's
in danger of running out of cash
you might ask why a commuter town like
woking needs a Skyline like Singapore
but these towers are the products of a
system whose demands whose incentives
have changed with less funding from
central government councils were urged
to find new revenue streams
the man who changed those incentives was
Lord Eric pickles who served as
Secretary of State for communities and
local government under the coalition
government from 2010. essentially to
give them more power give them more say
and give them more say of how they spend
things and it's called localism and it
really was designed to give get power
down to the lowest level in local
government councils are encouraged to be
more entrepreneurial there was less
Financial oversight was it a surprise
then you have councils like thoric like
Croydon that ran into huge amounts of
trouble oh I would have said so I think
a lot of it boils down to a lack of due
diligence but the ones that you talk
about I think that there's been a kind
of a real problem with it sort of moved
into this without properly thinking it
through for many councils it feels like
the fight of their lives and even at the
parish level things can get very heated
I have no
Jackie Weaver was catapulted into
internet notoriety they now elect a
chairman no they can't listen to Vice
chair is here I take charge when a
parish council Zoo meeting descended
into chaos
over I would say the last 10 years
probably we've seen the district and
County council's ingestion disappeared
the County Council disappeared
altogether
um contract so much that now they only
perform their statutory functions now
that means all the kind of community
stuff that is visible that makes us feel
good
doesn't happen anymore they don't have
any money to do it they only focus on
the statutory obligations
a government spokesperson told us we're
making an additional 5.1 billion pounds
available for councils in England in the
next financial year
we're also providing multi-year
certainty to local government outlining
spending over the next two years to
allow councils to plan ahead with
confidence
but certainty and confidence are in
short supply for those of us who rely on
councils who've seen Services reduced or
removed and wonder what's going next
those threads are cut and the fabric
eventually unravels Tom Cheshire Sky
News